herr kessler sie finden ja gut dass
alice schwarzer diese debatte angestoßen
hat gemeinsam mit den anderen natürlich
frau gehört eben erwähnt wie viele schon
unterzeichnet haben wo sehen sie denn
die lösung oder wo befinden sie sich
jetzt hier in dem unterschiedlichen
meinungsspektrum naja ist ein
unterschiedliches meinungsspektrum das
ist schon mal sehr wichtig dass sie das
sagen wir reden eine unterschiedliche
meinungen und wenn man über meinungen
unterschiedliche art rede das ist schon
mal besser als wenn man sich die köpfe
einschlägt man sieht auch jetzt an der
erhitzt seit jetzt hier gleich mal artig
gewissermaßen explodiert
wie dünn doch die zündschnur wie kurz
die zündschnur geworden ist und mich
erinnern dass teilweise ich will für
ihre frage mich nicht drücken aber mich
ändern die art und weise wie wir eben
debattieren dieser ganzen debatte
teilweise an verwundungen die wir uns
gegenseitig zugefügt haben in der korona
debatte zwei jahre lang da ging es auch
um angst da gab es eine gute angst angst
vor corona die dann gewisse
verhaltensmaßregeln nahegelegt hat
teilweise staatlich aufoktroyiert es gab
eine schlechte angst die angst vor der
impfung es gab leute die gute argumente
hatten es gebe leute die schlechte
argumente hatten und meinungen die vom
mainstream oder von einer
mehrheitsmeinung abwichen wurden lange
nicht als abweichende meinung gesehen
sondern als moralische defekte dessen
der diese abweichende meinungen äußert
das ist glaube ich eine lehre aus krone
und wir reden teilweise ansatzweise ja
auch schon in der ukraine frage als
hätten wir nichts gelernt oder als wären
wir nicht in der lage etwas zu lernen
aus diesen debatten wir tauschen hier
meinungen aus wir müssen die texte dann
wirklich schon ganz genau lesen ich habe
es auch kritische anfragen an diesen
text gar keine frage aber wir müssen
glaube ich die meinung von dem stärker
trennen der sie äußert schreibt mir die
wichtigste lehre zu sein aus der krone
debatte die meinung von dem trennen der
sie äußert ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen
das ist jetzt eine debatte da kann ich
das lineal anlegen wo ich will und ich
bekomme keine geradeheraus muss ich ganz
klar sagen ich bin selbstverständlich
auch für frieden ich bin aber auch sehr
dafür dass herr putin diesen krieg nicht
gewinnt ich bin sehr dafür dass wir der
ukraine nicht sagen welche ziele sie zu
erreichen hat ich bin aber auch sehr
dafür dass wir nicht sagen wir müssen
jetzt fünf sechs sieben jahre lang die
aller schärfsten waffen die wir haben
permanent ohne ansehen der jeweiligen
situation in die ukraine senden das
heißt ich bin wirklich für eine
abrüstung auch in der debatte dass wir
uns mehr in diesen positionen aber ich
muss wirklich sagen michael dass etwas
an die situation die kennen sie bestimmt
alle im golf von korinth da gab's killer
und charybdis zwei meeresungeheuer
entweder man ist links vorbei dann wird
man aufgefressen oder man ist rechner
dabei wurde aufgefressen man kam nicht
richtig durch und meine sorge ist ein
wenig dass wir uns hier in dieser
debatte in der wir wirklich nur in
anführungszeichen meinungen austauschen
und den kopf so einschlagen als könnten
wir hier am tisch wirklich diese
verfahrene situation erklären das wäre
ein wichtiger appell lasst uns wirklich
verbal auch abrüsten und schauen was
eine position ist die wir vor unserem
eigenen gewissen zu einem gewissen und
unserem eigenen wissen auch verantworten
da würde ich diese debatte ist wie alle
meinungen die in deutschland geäußert
werden für den verlauf des krieges um
kleine völlig irrelevant ist ein
argument mehr halten mehr für den
ausrüster oder abrüsten spielt für den
ausgang der geschichte kann aber
vielleicht trotzdem